uh good morning everybody
are you all going I heard it was a late
night last night on some some work at
Council sound like we were
ripping well is your chance to correct
my impression I had a late night with
Ross as well so I think they were very
different
look thank you uh for being here this
morning I understand you've got a full
day and we have actually
um a very good agenda
um and I just want to thank staff
Patricia
I think probably Andrew and Rihanna
there are probably a bunch of other
staff members that have contributed
significantly to this agenda and it's
substantially encouraging the way it's
developing and my appreciation for that
but we do want to make reasonably quick
moves
um uh just given what's in front of us
before I indicate the agenda because
there are a couple of changes I'd like
to make do we have any apologies we have
one from uh Tom who I think's already
gone up to kimagoya is on his way
do we have any other reports Evelyn is
not is not going to be here so we should
note Evelyn as anybody else that uh
should we know okay well I'll move from
the chair that we sustain those
apologies do I have a second to please
thanks ringy I'll put that motion all
those in favor please say aye those
against us carried is there any matters
in front of us for today's agenda that
you need to note your interests
there being none let's finally go to
public forum there's hadn't been formed
of any Patricia Michael malovica so we
will move on
um
uh just to indicate a small change
hopefully we've got Chris on the line
have we malavika Chris Janae
can you just um I'd just like to hurry
him along because I actually we were
Keen to change your agenda so we could
accommodate Chris which would be fine
um assuming uh Chris comes on board
while I
um uh while I uh just deal with the
agenda
um look we are it's good that Chris is
with us we've got a couple of items and
I propose to take those first and in
fact at your request knobby we'll deal
with the fee proposal first because you
need to shoot through in about 10
minutes for a while then we will then we
will deal with the um the update on the
annual report then I'll go back to item
four uh which is the minutes and we will
keep going through
um uh partly through through my likeness
um I'm actually going to remove the item
which is a review of the performance and
the effectiveness of the Autumn risk
committee I prepared some papers but for
reasons technical reasons they went
uploaded
is anticipated on Thursday morning and I
would rather we dealt with this more
properly uh uh so I'm going to suggest
that we hold that over until the next
meeting so that you think you have a
chance to see what I've written
um uh so apart from that I think that is
to proposed agenda will break at 10
o'clock for what I understand is hot
scones and butter
um I don't know which is the dominant uh
ingredient in that feed and uh the cup
of tea and a lunch at
12 noon and I anticipate we will have
finished our meeting by then
so um perhaps I should just move a
motion that we uh we confirmed the
agenda and the order that I've said
diversity please thank you Leslie I put
the motion all those in favor please say
aye and those against it's Carrie thanks
a lot right any sign of Chris at the
stage Madame can we move on to item four
which is the confirmation of the
um agenda
um I'll I'll put the motion that we
thought this true and correct recorder
of a second uh thank you Darren are
there any matters of accuracy or
completeness that people need to raise
looked pretty good to me I'll put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
aye those against it's Carrie I noticed
or a few action on items on it but um
well done to the staff Patricia and team
um I think they're all picked up in the
course of our agenda
um so that's uh that's really
um neat thank you they were primarily
around the the risk maturity around the
health and safety and also around our
annual report so that's great and
encouraging
so it gets me back to uh waiting for
Chris who we haven't oh no we've got him
g'day Chris how are you
you need to take your microphone off and
show us your face please Chris
brilliant g'day Chris how are you
while Chris is just waiting to get us uh
um his microphone up and running
um uh as as suggested let's deal with um
item six which is sorry item seven which
is the audit fee proposal which is what
I'd like to deal with uh first
um so obviously your lead off and then
I'll ask Chris to speak um to uh his
letter Chris you're with us now are you
and you can we can hear you can you say
hi
no we can't hear you mate and I can't
see your microphone off
that's right yeah okay Patricia we'll
let Chris do his thing while you carry
on please okay so this is the um audit
fee proposal which should be for a three
year period This is a little unusual in
that the fee being proposed by Chris for
this order is only for the 2023 audit
only
um allowing us to have a look at what it
actually really takes to complete the
audit of the ICC group
is um those that have been around this
table for a number of years know there
has been a significant increase in the
number of hours required to complete the
audit
um and the last two audits have been
somewhat complex
um and a number of different issues have
been dealt with during that and this
also coincides with the covert period
where audits went from being very much
more face to face on site to being
off-site and remote
which has had some
come added some additional complexities
to the audit process
so what um
what Chris is proposing here and
hopefully he'll
um get his microphone working shortly
um what he's proposing is that there's a
significant increase though when we look
at the breakdown that's been provided in
The Proposal letter a big chunk of that
is actually the increase in the hourly
cost of the auditors
and that was a significant increase they
set their audit fees out for three years
so the inflationary pressures on the
audit operation mean there's a
significant increase in that charge out
rate required
um The Proposal
after we take a the proposed discount
that we've got to is pretty much in line
with what we actually paid for last
year's fee after the overruns so this is
us saying let's see if this is the right
case we'd have a number of
um hours that we're working to Chris and
I are working very closely about
managing to those hours and this is what
we think is reasonable
um what is a little unusual is the
proposal to re-baseline after
the um audit's been completed so that we
can have a look at the number of Errors
spent and then talk with fellow councils
of similar size and complexity as us as
into how many hours their audit teams
are spending and seeing if there's
anything that we can do better to make a
more efficient process for both the
audit team and ourselves
now it's hopefully I see Chris back on
screen so do we have microphone yeah
Chris Chris if you have a chance to
speak and be welcome to I first invite
you to speak to you later please can you
give me yep did you Chris you can hear
me now no I can't hear you I hear you at
all literally um I can hear that you're
speaking but not not clearly are we able
to increase the volume on this yeah
that sounds like it's a Bluetooth issue
sign language
right are we not there are we Chris
I can eat you really well I'm not sure
I can only hear you frankly I can hear
you now better
um how are the rest of the committee
okay we will be we will be extremely
quiet Chris if you could uh continue
with your what you want to say please
I'll try and speak with some volume if I
can
um look thanks Bruce and good morning
everyone apologies for my technology
um as Patricia's outline the proposal
letter is in the packs um larger tape
that is red
um the purpose of the letter is
unsurprisingly to outline the phase
analysis of the contract period
um probably some highlights that are in
there really is yes it is a one-year fee
only there's Patricia's outline the Nets
because of the level of uncertainty
around the hours given the previous
history which is also at the India so
you'll see and some comparative
information it shows previous audit
hours have been between 2000 and 2 700
hours over the last
three years or so
um so yes we've proposed a one year fee
only and using using an open book
exercise to understand the hours better
which would be part of a two-way
conversation in terms of the analysis of
those hours and what it looks like for
our ears
um the fee is a significant increase is
Patricia's paper mentions
um the context for that there's another
letter and I think we discussed quite a
bit of it at the last committee
um talking around previous fee setting
parameters before covert
um and audit fees not keeping Pace with
the cost to complete audits equally
um you know increased complexity and
scope of audit since that time uh new
standards increasing expectations of
standard centers and Regulators
um and that was even leading into covert
when when fees needed to rise however
you know there was a pause put on at
that point
um given the impact of of costs on
communities so much what you would have
done yourself with your rates so we we
paused those fees through covert
um that cost pressure hasn't changed and
obviously we've seen quite a quite a
highly inflationary environment since
then so so this is the point at which
we're trying to get to to re-baselining
that and getting to what is a reasonable
fee both for ourselves and for you
um
the hours components of the increase are
included on page 34.
um they're also a Patricia's table and a
cover letter again these are primarily
pointing towards increased areas of
complexity around accounting issues such
as ICL evaluations and even matters
concerning the group consolidation we're
bringing in some new standards there
both auditing and Reporting some quality
review requirements and obviously that
level of re-based lining the cost impact
of those matters is also shown on page
um and as Patricia rightly outlined a
significant proportion of their
increases in relation to charge it rate
movements and the previous fee capping
so the impact of keeping the same scope
and putting in the same amount of hours
as we'd had in previous audit proposals
results of itself as 73
000 of the increase
um you'll also see in their proposed a
discount to the audit fee from its cost
recovery position
um that's just really because we're
cognizant of the magnitude of the
increase we're proposing here and just
trying to listen as much as we can on
2023 recognizing the remaining increases
obviously it's still quite significant
um
I think that's probably all I wanted to
cover Bros that have been taking
questions yeah thanks for that
um Chris and appreciate that we can hear
you now and that you're you're with us
that's great Darren you've got a
question thank you not a question but um
but but a comment and um it's probably
the first time in at least three years
that it's going to be a positive one
um we know we've had challenges with
audit over the recent years and and
quite clearly you've you've heard
council's concern about the uh the
increase in fees but this is I think a
really good response and that
uh you're prepared to work with us and
and
test things with rigor and take that
year for some uh comparisons good luck
in finding another Council of our size
and complexity Patricia
um
but I think it's you know it's a very
reasonable uh approach and so I just
wanted to say uh thank you for it
thanks there comment Darren brungie then
then knobby
um uh my my question I I guess is a
standard procurement question
that obviously we are procuring services
to do this and obviously this Council
audit New Zealand is not the only
provider for this is that right
um I think great you have to look at
this slightly differently
um rangi which is this is not a standard
procurement process
I'm not saying it's standard but it is a
procurement process sorry
um Used to Know uh Because by the public
audit Act
our auditor is the auditor general full
stop right there is no choice
in that so this is the auditor general
enabling in the middle this is where
you're getting closer to the alternates
to a provider providing that work this
is a fee that's effectively set by the
auditor general not Iowa New Zealand
right okay so it's the auditor general
that is that is essentially setting this
fee in fact that's one of the reasons
that's being late I understand across
that these fees have all been approved
and moderated by the auditor general
effectively himself okay so when it
comes to the amount of hours required
now in any service provider people can
do it quickly they can do it slowly they
can do it a hundred different ways so
how do we know that's what I'm getting
good question yep as is that the
provider is is providing the best value
for the alley you know per hour
um
you know like I mean you know yourself
if you Ross is an accountant so I mean
people have their own accountants and
they normally stick with them it makes
sense there comes a point that that even
any business will go hey this is this is
not right we need
we need to do a review because it
doesn't feel right
thanks ringing so I like I think the key
question is actually how do we know this
is the right number of hours so what
what's happened and I probably would
invite you Patricia as well as you Chris
how do we know this is the right number
of hours given it's such a key to turn
and it's the total overall cost
um so from my perspective I looked at it
based on the number of hours that was
actually spent last year and going we
probably spent too many hours in certain
areas to bring it back
um I have had some off the record
conversations with colleagues around the
country but roughly what their ordered
hours are to go this is looking at about
that knowing some of the complexities at
other councils but I'll pass over to
Chris because he may be
better place to sort of answer that
question
Chris
yep I'm happy to say that I think um two
very sensible responses there Patricia
um I I take comfort from from the
moderation process and the hours of
similar audits
um equally I think you know we're
cognizant the comparative hours and
you'll see them and all their
um and you'll see them in all the glory
I wish and so Glory but you know what I
mean in the meter there and you know
we're trying to take the inefficiencies
out of there and set what is a
reasonable set of hours for for an audit
and that takes into account and it takes
into account efficiency so a lot of time
has gone into going over those past
costs and pulling out what is
effectively an efficient time and
looking at the base I think part of your
question as well
um rangi was around
um scope
um I mean at the end of the day we're
set to to a level of what's a minimum
under all its standards but
um you know that is driven by risk
assessment so more risk more work Miss
Restless work we're being heavily
challenged at the moment around our risk
assessments to ensure that we are
pulling those down to an appropriate
Manner and it's not in my my interests
or my team's interested doing the end
this series work either so in terms of
the scope question there's a lot of
challenge going in there to making sure
we're doing the right amount of work
um I think from from an efficiency angle
you know that's a shared responsibility
and it's something that Patricia's team
and my team have been putting a lot of
effort into ensuring that there's good
preparation from yourselves and good
execution from ourselves as well so
there's a lot there's a lot in there
um that certainly a focus on trying to
keep it to what is a good reasonable
efficient audit
no thanks Chris appreciate that
um uh
Grant I apologize I need to be away in
about five minutes
um just to reflect that um I've had some
discussions with Chris and Patricia and
Michael internally as well about the fee
structures going forward
um it's a little bit eye-watering that
um within a two-year period we're going
up a hundred thousand one year and
another 100 000 potentially next year as
well because we don't have the three
year forecast
um and so when I look at the reasons
that are driving that up I see two
things one that we can't control and one
that we should be making some noise on
uh the one we can't control is the price
of auditors
um and we probably can't as part of that
go beyond what the order the general is
determining either the new schedule of
work that needs to be looked at but it
doesn't seem logical to me that this
whole process is Cost Plus
um I've done quite a bit of audit work
in the government sector and there comes
a time when instead of just saying we've
got a hundred fifteen hundred hours here
and and the AG says next year we want
another 200 hours and there's another
bit of work on another bit of work on
another bit of work and you end up with
two and a half thousand hours sometimes
in the public sector the the mindset is
look if we've done some basic work back
here year on year on year and we've
found little or nothing we start to put
that aside and what that does is it
still ends up being 15 or 1600 hours but
it doesn't mean it keeps adding on every
single year as as the
flavor of the uh
AG decides that there's more work that
may need to be doing because the
industry just keeps building and the oil
Mountain Air eye watering that between
one year that we've gone up 61 on budget
I mean we can't run an organization that
way we wouldn't allow any contractor to
do that to us and I think rangi was
alluding to the contract stuff and it's
all very well for the order the general
will say well you've got to deal with
all that New Zealand there's no
disrespect to Chris because he's been
really positive
um but there are other options and I and
I guess it's a little bit of a close
field in some ways I think now another
advice I'm getting is that Deloitte who
are also in the picture
um are also experienced the same sort of
costs as well
um so we're probably not getting away
from it but it's whether we need to do
everything
back in there back room if you had five
years of checking I don't know counts
payable or accounts receivable or
something like that and you find no
faults or no potential risks at all then
why wouldn't you just de-risk that so
that you can incorporate other work that
you bring in and I guess that's probably
a big picture issue Beyond today's paper
I guess but well I I know I know local
government New Zealand are looking to
there yeah because they're they're
feeling that the pinch on the cost as
well I suspect I suspect you're at a
general has got lots of letters um if
they're not potentially out of the
conference there being some move with
the audit Journal about its fees I
wonder if I just make a comment on that
though now because I I wanted to pick up
on your point before Grant and then
Leslie I think I've got an order here
one of the things
um Chris that you have uh said or rather
has been highlighted by you Patricia and
page 28 of our agenda is that we will
treat this what I really what I'm really
saying is Chris has put a song
performance
because we paid an extra 95
000 for our last order essentially
in part because of our level of
performance or quite frankly normal
performance
well we could have done better
performance to minimize cost let's try
and find the right around it plus some
of the challenges of things like like
accounting for ICL
and so what I'm seeing here is actually
a challenge let's keep our noses cleaner
that's our next paper when we we have a
good report from Patricia about how we
can have confidence that we can deliver
so that Chris can do his work but what I
do notice here Chris is a commitment to
an open book exercise
um uh in the lead up to that 24 25 and
I'd like to put a time-boundedness on
that open book exercise being reviewed
and after the the first our first
meeting after the 31st of October
I would like us to have that open book
analysis
on the audit and I think it needs a
level of nuance not just these were the
hours therefore these must be the hours
next year that's not open book even if
I'm going back to your good point
running that actually an open book with
a contractor is not just well these are
the hours I want to understand why they
are the hours
um so Patricia and Chris unless you guys
want to make more comment I would like
that to Be an Effective discussion in
our first meeting so it's probably quite
frankly it's probably December whatever
the first one is I can't remember my
dates past adoption of the accounts
but we need to have sit down around a
table and we can work out whether that's
Workshop or whether that's
um it's somewhere it's got to come back
to an open meeting we actually we have
that open book exercise and understand
why they are where they are so not be we
come back to your point
why are these areas focused on why are
they risky I think we have a right
without over stressing that is enough as
a right we have a need to understand why
the scope of the exercise take of the
order takes its length so I'd like to
just note that but sorry Grant and then
Leslie yeah thanks cheers so just on
page 31 recent cost history the
estimates on budgeted as versus actual
airs who's done those estimates
historically
historically they're done by audit by
the way they ordered a journey
I do believe and Chris will confirm that
those estimates would be put together by
his team and then moderated by the
auditor general right okay so so
therefore yes so therefore what
confidence can we get that the 1500 is
this time is accurate and if you're
confident that it's accurate then what
can you issue us with a fixed price
contract I.E whatever the ears are the
price those are so
and then that puts to the cheers point a
bit of pressure back on all that New
Zealand around the fact that you know
you're saying you've done a robust
discovery of what ears are required
that's good
we'll take a fixed price contract so
irrespective of The Heirs in an open
book review the price is the price
because otherwise there's no
accountability we can't go to the market
and tender it because it's a monopoly
and the only confidence we can get that
audit new zealanders
being effective in terms of the use of
their time
is that they put the skin in the game
around a fixed Posh contract
and that would be my view on the only
way we can bring discipline from their
end to us
thanks Ryan Leslie thank you Mr chair um
my slightly different view is that I was
going to comment that this is a a
pragmatic approach which is refreshing
after last year and
it is offering as Patricia's pointed out
in the covering piece
um to use the 2023 order to re-baseline
what is required and I actually think we
need that we have we have definitely got
to the point where we need that rebase
line to happen
um in that way I see this as a pragmatic
way of getting a much better result for
the future
so I'm tending to think that
the best the best thing is to go forward
with this be very serious about that
rebase lining as your pointed out Mr
chair
um and hopefully
um get the three-year agreed figure or
have a rebase line that we can use to
approach
one of the other big companies
can I ask thank you for that easily
appreciate it with any other questions
sir I've got a couple questions here's
Ross
again I think it's pragmatic and
speaking in it don't leave with other
local authorities really
risk committing industry around the
country they have seen similar
percentage increases I've also seen
their set for three years with rather
large increases year on year so I think
we're fortunate that
we've got a good approach looking at
this year and then going forward in
respect to the fixed price I'd be
I I don't think you'd find a
professional service advisor willing to
do that without some really strict scope
because you'll have what's in scope and
then what's out of scope and no water as
we said last year runs smoothly so there
will always be some argument about what
else is there so
um I think this is a good base for this
year we could move forward on that
right thank you for that just a couple
of questions so
um uh in some sense Chris
um there's a sense of incentivization
here you really want to charge eighty
thousand dollars above uh what the
proposed fee is for the current year
correct
all being equal you would be charging us
something in the order of three hundred
and forty thousand dollars I think
correct
that's the fee on a cost recovery basis
on a cost recovery basis okay
so bottom bottom line is that we have
the incentive we perform you perform
and it's to I'm sorry I'm in front of me
262 or something or thereabouts thousand
dollars that becomes cemented and as the
Baseline not the 360 correct or 340
correct
um this is about a smoothing increase so
the discount agree through negotiation
there is a smoothing process so that
that possibly could change in our years
to be discussed
right so we are signing we are
ultimately signing up to three three
forty plus inflation in there yes
not necessarily that's part of our
discussion for next year right I
appreciate the exercise I just think we
need to keep we need to tie this down
and my uh my view my view is that
actually we do it right Etc the Baseline
is set at 262.
Chris one other thing that's slightly
picky uh in your letter I was a wee bit
um disappointed with uh the additional
cost and I would be able to know if you
had a view on what additional cost was
because we requested the Auditors done
on site has the audit approach changed
that we wouldn't do it on site that's on
page 36 where it says the increase in
proposed disbursements reflects the
audit team performing more on-site work
this year at your request that is
probably a question to me okay
um
that is my request so last year we had
very little
um staff involvement on site
um a lot of it was done remotely and it
wasn't done face to face so that was
about to be one of the reasons
um for a lot of miscommunication between
the audit team and the council Finance
team
um because it was being done by email
rather than a conversation we have
requested that there be more continuous
on-site presents from the audit team
through the audit
um so that we can get that Cadence of
how back in the back in my day it would
have not been done by email it would
have been done face to face and there
are some nuances being missed as a
result of communication by emails that
we wanted to cut out so it's just trying
to work out
I recognize that it's costing slightly
more but Chris and I have had some
discussions about how we can get the
most effective use out of having people
on site versus off
so and and slight increase in
disbursements for improved quality and
efficiency in the actual audit City for
the the hours fees down I get that
Leslie thanks Mr chair look I I do
remember quite clearly
um that very point being raised several
times last year
in my own experience from the health
sector of on-site Auditors would say
that it is always a preference
we've got used to doing many things
electronically and by zoom and email and
so forth but
in the audit case I think there's a
there's a huge lot of advantages in the
on-site communication happening and I've
seen it with other audits
thank you Leslie yes possibly final
comment running oh look just just the
final commenters to support grants
comments about
and fixed price
um recently Council passed a fixed price
contract
um actually you know like pretty
eye-watering amount and and that was
done
um and we we did all the time and I
can't see what there's so mystical and
magical about doing an audit sorry
um I think it's getting sort of a bit
blown out of proportion on how
um sort of complex it is really and and
so I'm totally agreeable to the fixed
price if that was ever achievable
we've had the arguments from Ross I
Wonder If we're getting to the point now
where we somebody might be prepared to
move the Motions that are here
thank you Leslie thank you Darren
right there's any further debate or will
I put that motion
okay I'll put the motion then all those
in favor please say aye
aye those against
Grant
you will record your okay great so the
motion the motion has passed thank you
appreciate that thank you Chris
um and uh why don't we just move for the
next time because I would like to make
some by the way very positive comments
about Chris but I think they come up
with the next one as well so let's uh
let's let's move to the annual report
update uh which is uh what item whatever
the previous item was
thanks Patricia I suspect us in your
hands again it's in my head so this is a
ction an update of where we are with the
inner report preparation and my Banks
should leave my proforma sitting up on
the at the top table so there is a pro
forma in existence the guy the team are
busy working through some of those key
time frames we have a very detailed
project plan that we're working to
um you've got the key Milestone dates
there
um we are tracking to those at the
moment but we're probably wanted to
focus the team so there are already two
audits that have been underway and if
not pretty close to being finished
um in fact we started auditing before
the end of the financial year on some of
the small smaller entities and the next
ones the first of the big ones is the
airport company that will come in in a
couple of weeks so the team are very
busy getting ready for those
um Chris and his team have been in for a
couple of weeks during the start of June
to do the interim and actually while
because there's still some pieces that
haven't been finished and given the time
pressure there is no report from Chris
on that and the findings from the
interim order it will be wrapped into
the final order
but the team did actually make some
start on what would be testing that
would normally be done during the main
audit period so we were working together
about how we could most efficiently use
the audit stuff that they had and air
staff availability at the time so we've
actually Advanced some things that would
typically be left towards the end of the
audit and bought them forward
um
which was really good to work through
but the key issues is probably what we
probably need to discuss so as typically
at the moment the valuation of property
plan and Equipment will be an issue we
have made the call that we will be
valuing roading again even though we
only valued it last year the significant
cost increases within
basically the whole
infrastructure sector
um are still there
um so by revaluing roading um
we don't have to revalue any other
classes so we'll be doing that
um
the what will be a key issue and is
still an emerging issue is how how we
will be treating the investment in and
the loan to ICL there's some technical
accounting issues that the team are
working through and we're working really
closely with Chris and his team on that
the other key issue and it's always an
issue
um is the timely receipt of finalized
reports from all the subsidiaries not
all the subsidiaries are within my
direct control
so we are reliant on other orders firms
so it's not all living with Chris with
audit New Zealand actually completing on
time and if they are late it will cause
pressure on us
and can pressure on Chris's team to
receive those signed off reports from
subsidiaries and the consolidation is
impacted as a result
so that we are trying to manage as best
we can
but a complicated group structure is not
helpful if we do not have more than 50
but we still need to bring in those
numbers we don't tend to have that much
sway
the other one which is an issue that
emerged last year in relation to the
change in water standards regulations
we have some number of key Department of
internal affairs dictated performance
measures in relation to our drinking
water
standards
but
they've changed but we're still required
to have those performance measures so
last year we required a third party
consultant to give an opinion about our
compliance with those we need to again
this year
but there's not very clear guidance to
the sector yet about what they actually
need to give an opinion on
and we sort of need this opinion by in
the next three weeks we've made a call
about what we think that is but there's
a risk that
central government May or the DIA may
change that unless Something's Happened
in the last couple of days from Chris
can give an update it is an issue that
the whole sector is facing all of those
with drinking water
Patricia Chris has any comments from
your side in terms of the progress of
the 23 audit uh Chris welcome your
comments
um thanks for the update Patricia it's
good there I think probably I'll just
talk to the key issues matters I think
in terms of the internal the interim
audit the context there in terms of the
work that we're looking to complete is
is in relation to one area and our it
Auditors who are currently doing their
work at the moment they look at all the
back end of everything and do all their
I.T work so I'm hoping to have that
shortly
um in terms of those key issues there I
think the first thing to say is they add
the right ones which give you some
comfort until they are the right ones
from my perspective
um sorry I'm just gonna call for a
second
um and I think that last one's probably
worth mentioning so the the drinking
water standards assessment there is the
case of having two sets of rules for one
year unfortunately a performance
measures based on the first set of set
of rules um and that performance
measures dictated by a set of rules
issued by the DIA
um they've yet to be updated to see what
happens after November
um there's a level of logic to what that
measure could be given given you've
reported on it previously but you see
that skype's really important in terms
of determining what your expert can look
at and ultimately how how we can use
that expert's work to get Assurance over
drinking water quality measures
thanks Chris Academy of comments from
folk at all along the committee
just a couple of questions from me uh
probably your way um Patricia
um is there a how developed is that Pro
former I know it's sitting here I
haven't I haven't gone across the reach
for it it is it has um very well
developed I didn't share it because it's
through you know 100 and nearly 200
pages and a lot of the commentary still
needs to be updated as we're going
through but we are getting well through
it it's pretty much a drop my comment at
the last meeting Patricia was was
actually any sense a chance for the
committee to see something early and I
did use the word pro forma
um uh to the extent that it would
presumably show us the the tenor of what
how we're going to report particularly
the front end
appreciating numbers won't necessarily
be there Etc so
um I'm not you know overly worried but
what I am concerned about is that the
committee has a chance and a timely
fashion to be able to provide comment on
a relatively dry set of accounts because
otherwise we see it the week before we
do to adopt we're not going to make any
changes even if they should be credibly
done because actually we want to get the
darn thing out of the way so
um just looking at your timetable on
page 23 when is the chance for the
committee to have that sort of pro forma
View and provide you with comments that
was that the next meeting on the 19th of
September okay good that's fine then
we'll do it then that's that's what I
need to know
um look and the other question was
actually and you've touched on the
subsidiaries and you've got a list there
on page 24. possibly this is well to
both of you some of those are more equal
than others in terms of their impact on
our group results
and I suspect that we have in the past
how to count signed off with some
unaaudited
entries as well as some audited entries
is that going to happen again this year
um based on progress to date I'm not
expecting that I'm expecting them all to
come through the risk is actually coming
out of the ichl group because they are
the more material subsidiaries council's
direct ones are perhaps not as material
and you have assurances that ichl will
deliver on time
I have right and Chris I suspect you're
the auditor are you
yes for ichl airport brilliant okay
right so we need to we need to make
certain that I see you smiling dear
Andrew is there any comment you want to
make cover
one comment and this is probably not
fair to crease so I don't really expect
an answer but it touches on some of the
issues that have been raised
particularly around who the order is and
and
I accept the comments around the
complexity in ICL and the difficulty
that is causing for audit New Zealand
um the point that we will probably flag
is that there might be an auditor if
that could be delegated out there might
be an auditor that would solve some of
that complexity and I think that's as I
said Chris that's without notice so I
don't really expect an answer but I
think that's something that all the
parties should consider we're getting
some complexity down in the holding
company group that is
testing the commercial sensibility of
order at New Zealand that might
deserve some consideration of an
external auditor
well I think debt reflects that the
previous item where we talked about the
open book exercise it should be across
the group and not the and not just the
parent uh entity so thanks to their
communitary
um just one other question I had which
was in terms of efficiency Patricia
um uh I haven't had it done and so I
can't comment on its efficiency but
indexation versus full revaluation of
Roads is indexation a quicker way to get
this done yes and are you indexing yes
ah okay right and we'll probably index
in one of the subsidiaries as well so
yeah so indexation is much quicker we'll
work closely with the audit team because
this is a new approach
um for us and making sure that we cross
all their T's and Dot errors oh that's
great thank you great yeah thanks cheers
so um just to pick up on Andrew's point
um what's what is the opportunity to
actually bring an external person in
with more commercial
um
Acumen for a better term to enable that
oshl order to be completed on time
because I agree with you you know it's
the best I think that's probably going
to trip us up
um so I'd be interested to get some
comment on that of course I think I
think actually
um Andrew tried to say that simply it's
probably unfair to ask Chris to comment
on that at this stage
um so I'll reframe it when would we get
a response from Chris around the
opportunity to do that well I think I
was reflecting that would be at the time
we do the open book exercise
after the order
but it'll be too late uh well I think I
think
we are past balance State now we are in
a process where we've got to get the
order done we're not going to change
horses now I don't think which would be
the which would be the you know an
implication so say from what from what
it from what Andrew is so here's the
process of auditing noise at gel
actually started can't tell you yes it
has it has started it has started okay
okay and then second question just with
respect to the
um revaluation of roading that's due to
the fact that because of the change and
but well the perceived change in value
there's a material impact on balance
your rock yes
it will also have an impact on our
depression depression yeah that's all
those parts of the roads that are
depreciable uh Grant as well yeah that's
right and that's what I was thinking it
actually great great pressure that's an
issue yeah yeah absolutely
it's a circular issue yeah it's a
problem isn't it inflation and
inflationary periods we actually and it
has material impact on right you've got
it absolutely yeah so something yeah
absolutely so it's something to be
worried about certainly and that will
obviously as you will know play out on
the long-term Place yeah yeah that's
true look I'm going to move that we we
uh um we
um pass these resolutions you're not
just making so doing a brief coming
which is
um
I'm encouraged by the conversation
including your comments granted Andrew
that actually we've got a robust
relationship now with our Auditor in a
way that's quite frankly we didn't have
last year
uh and I'm comfortable
that actually we both enable Patricia
and support her in the plans that we
have got to deliver our part of the
story but I also want to say that um
I've also had the chance to meet with
Chris a couple of times and I am much
encouraged
by the way he is approaching the issues
that we face and we've dealt with those
in this paper so I'm I'm positive I
think right at the start there and he
might have started with the fee one
saying you know the the there's
something positive here I want to
reflect that my engagement with Chris as
our auditor has been positive today and
I'm looking forward to ensure we
continue that in light of that to see it
see it work so I'm very keen that we do
that so look I've moved the motion that
we do all those three things dive a
signal please thank you grab your second
any other discussion I've been on a
parallel those in favor please say aye
aye those against that's Carrie thank
you thank you Patricia thank you Chris
you're welcome to say if you wish but
otherwise um we'll let you get on with
the busy day that no doubt you have
Chris so it's great to have you here
oh Pop away thanks very much thanks
Chris
can I move now to item five please which
is the customer complaint uh Mariana is
this is going to be comments from you or
Joe Joe and Hannah are going to speak to
this one thank you Rihanna g'day Joe how
are you
oh we've got snacks
speaking
um the customer complaints policy will
look to provide consistency across the
organization
and so that there's a transparency to
the process for everybody involved
it will also look to highlight
opportunities to enhance the customer
experience through continuous
Improvement
um for each complain to complaint
liaison will be appointed to that
incident so that the customer will have
the one person to deal with and will
have an understanding from both parties
within set time frames
so we'd like to invite any questions
thanks Joe
all right coming to focus Grant yeah
thanks Joe um so just with respect to
recent events with through Spanish
Palace would would that scenario have
come through this complaints process
is that what you're sort of thinking
and so I'm the policy analyst here so
that's my involvement in this um the the
thinking is
um
part of this process has been to
understand what a complaint is and is
not so a lot of things that are raised
and that come through our various
services are actually dealt with there
and then
um it's when that cannot be resolved
immediately or there's an ongoing
problem then it will be escalated to a
complaint so it will depend on the
specific circumstances but um there's a
helpful chart on
um on page three of the report which is
um hopefully gives a bit of an
indication of how we deal with various
incidents but there'll be um very
circumstance specific yeah yeah because
I mean further comment that you know
it's important both for the public but
equally for staff that they feel
supported that they don't have to deal
with an issue that they ain't aren't
able to deal with you know it's out of
their sort of
sphere of influence yes
yes step to be a formal complaint yeah
so for that case yes that would have
been yeah and it would have gone into
this system yeah because it would be
treated as a formal complaint have you
tested the process with the same Splash
Palace staff to just see if they felt
supported around the process that we're
proposing um not this specifically yet
but part of this will be training so
everyone has a full understanding of
where they're at yeah we did test a
number through this process okay
um and probably the most challenging
thing was to identify what is a
complaint because the customer will ring
up and go I'd like to complain my bin
hasn't been collected but we can fix
that very quickly yeah
um and the first because tends to be the
call center that ears most of this first
and they um will often say this is going
a bit wrong and that's why that would
then step into the complaint and it
would go through the process with the
set time frames so everybody again
understands yeah timing around that yes
okay thank you
um
regarding complaints that are put to
elected members now what is the what is
the protocol for an elected member to
basically
until you just act as the heart back and
feed it out kick it for touch or what
what do you think do you uh or do you
track down does he let the member try
and track down the relative uh person
which I don't think is quite Fair no no
so it is we where would I go I've got
two sitting in emails that have come
this week
um what we would encourage you to do was
before that onto
offices we would then respond to that
customer within two days often okay
what's the email and the customer dot
service at ICC okay
um and that is absolutely the best place
if you can encourage the customer to
speak to us directly we appreciate that
because often we can find out a lot more
about that but yes just forward that to
our main email and then we will stop the
process or try and resolve it in the
first instance quickly I mean it's it's
good that they they see elected members
as being a way into Council
um of course but we just need to be we
just know you need to know anything yeah
thank you yeah
I wonder look just following that
question out wrong you know I appreciate
your point is that clear on the policy
what an elected member does when they
receive a complaint
to be fair um I don't think it's
explained in extreme detail although
again if you look at that um
chart uh registry page 14 yeah yeah um
it does say customer contact ICC by any
means and no I didn't specifically say
um elected member but but I would say
that's that's part and parcel so
um anyone who is part of council can
receive a complaint and then pass it on
to the the correct person can I can I I
would like to suggest that you need to
be more clear okay I take the broad
assumption but I think policies
sometimes are to clarify the assumptions
that we're all probably operating under
imminently reasonable it doesn't change
it but I think that would be valuable
that it recognizes that this is a system
that works for for men elected members
receiving complaints as well as staff
yep you know Frontline Frontline staff
would be useful any other questions for
escribe yeah sorry just one further one
so this then would fit into our risk
management framework so if the complaint
was significant it would then fit into a
monitoring management program to come to
this yes to this committee okay yep cool
thanks
are there any questions actually on the
policy we've made one little comment
here which hopefully is said
respectfully was there any other
questions folk would like to raise
a couple if that's okay please if I just
started with the diagram
you got you've got requests for services
and you've got complaints and I mean I
take you on board the immediate sorry
the I take on board that that sort of
Distinction what is a result immediately
if it's not a request for service or a
complaint
I was entered the
service it could be someone doesn't know
how to
um
use the parking kiosk so we pop outside
and actually show them and help them so
it comes to us via many different forms
um social media you know lots of other
ways so some things it's just literally
picking up the phone and you can sort it
out very quickly for the customer
um when we put the policy together the
biggest work on was what is a request
for service and when does it get to the
point that actually that person has
asked for that three times and we still
haven't fixed it and that's where in
customer service we will be lodging that
as a complaint so then the complaint
liaison can deal directly with that
customer to check it is resolved okay
great is a cold reader of the policy I
didn't quite get that distinction I mean
I've made it again I've made an
assumption yes that it resolved
immediately is something which actually
doesn't have to really get to the RFS or
isn't actually a complaint yes but
equally
it's not well defined can I be honest
it's not well defined so I just I passed
that on as a as a as a critique not a
criticism thank you um the other thing
then that that interests me is actually
your description about a formal
complaint and I didn't know what a
formal complaint was was it one where
they have to give us their name and
contact details what what what actually
is a formal complaint if I might answer
that um chair and I think a lot of the
confusion issue here is that the word
complaint has a colloquial meaning
versus the meaning that we want to give
it in the policy
um and again we we under nard about
exactly what word to use we tried
registered complaint we tried formal
complaint
um we settled on complaint and um and
then we have that section in the policy
itself that talks about what is a
requested service versus a complaint
that is going into this system the
phrasing formal complaint shows up in
the cover report we try to away from it
I don't think we used it in the policy
itself
um for for that reason the report is
trying to sort of speak to that
colloquial use of the word complaint and
what we're trying to say is that
um certain things
the are called complaints by the
customer won't reach that level
um but other things will so I fully
accept that there is a slightly confused
wording we've tried to be very
consistent in the policy itself and just
use the word complaint
um but I think the point is that the
upshot is the same that um if someone
approaches council with an issue
whatever that issue is it's either going
to be resolved immediately or it's going
to result in a request for service or
it's going to result in a complaint that
goes into this system
um again I appreciate there's a little
bit of muddying of the wording but I
think the policy is is clear enough that
that's what we're looking at and we
tried to make this a user-friendly
policy and avoid too much jargon
um because we assume that members of the
public whilst I trust no one will ever
have a complaint against ICC on the rare
occasion that they did I imagine they
would want to read this and and
understand it and what we want them to
understand is that phone us
and we will deal with it but if you are
told that this doesn't amount to a
complaint that's why but then there's
always the option that someone can say
well I think this is a complaint and I
want you to register it in which case
fine we can do that I think a critical
party and you go I think you already
heard is this is going to be obviously
in light of adoption of this policy
there's going to be a lot of training
and I think that needs to be clarified
if I what there needs to be a strong
understanding about the conventions
behind what is a complaint and what it's
not I mean I would point out that you do
have a particular section on a formal
complaint within the policy and I didn't
understand it so I just passed it on for
what it's worth thank you thank you
um uh sorry just one other uh question
and I just want to say to the members
and and look I not quite soon with as a
management or a governance policy I'm
sort of reasonably relaxed but I just
wanted to point numbers to page 19 of 93
we're in fact time frames are really
important because this is a level of
service
and I mean this is giving rise to the
commitment that you've actually guys
have given to us we want to you know
let's be out front if you've got a
complaint we'll we'll resolve it here
goes here goes the timelines we are
self-imposing on ourselves which you
know as a question is that reasonable I
mean I think it is but I just want to
point it out for members as we consider
the uh the the resolution
um
and uh that's that's fine it's
interesting um and and look at this is
me reflecting that often often sometimes
the matters that that become in the way
that you're suggesting Grant ones that
ultimately end up in this committee tend
to be more at the vexatious yes
potentially vexatious complainant end of
the scale and I wasn't quite certain
whether that sort of complaint where
ultimately you might say to a person
we're just not going to deal with you
does that that doesn't get registered as
a complaint
it would potentially start as a
complaint right and it will be through
the system so there may be a point that
we get to where we um have to withdraw
our interaction with that customer for
various reasons
um hopefully that can be restored again
um if um things settle and we can get
back into that but it was really
important in this policy that we covered
off fixations because we haven't had
that in writing yeah my point Joe was I
think even if even if the conclusion of
a complaint is that we go through a
reasonably formal process of of Michael
declaring a person is vexatious and we
won't deal with them we still want to
have that recorded in our in our system
yes
um so that particularly we can reflect
on how many complaints we've got how we
how we've been able to deal with them
effectively in those which have a you
know a problem with them thank you for
that I've got Darren and then ring
thanks following on from that chair uh
Hannah Rojo I'm not sure who wants to
have a crack at this but it's
it's easy to determine the aggressive
complaints
um but is it potentially subjective or
how do we determine the the vexatious
slash recidivist
complainant
I would say part of this is going to be
a learning curve as well uh we we take
comfort from the fact that customer
services deal with this day in and day
out and they they know what a vexatious
um or recidivist
um complainant looks like
um but we've deliberately built in a a
shorter review period for this policy so
that within the first year it's going to
be fully reviewed to make sure that
we're capturing exactly that sort of
thing
um and that was a very intentional
decision in this case okay I appreciate
it out to that as well
um we do have some customers that get in
touch with us a lot more than others
um and that's fine because often they're
letting us know things within our city
that needs work and we and you know we
record those and we deal with those it's
only really
um where we may be getting to issues
where customers are abusive Etc that we
would have to step in
um and deal with that but as Hannah said
this is what customer service do deal
with every day and we're just looking
for that opportunity where they can say
we need to help that customer a little
bit more we need to step in we need to
have a liaison who's dealing with them
so the other thing to note as well when
we've spoken to other councils which we
have done a lot of research when we put
this policy in
true complaints they tend to only get
three or four a month
so I think it will be interesting when
we start the policy and do the training
to see if people are either sort of over
enthusiastic with using it and if we may
need to look at the training again or
how that policy is adopted because we
intend to try and fix absolutely
everything but sometimes you know it may
we know because it's not within our
level of service or within that time
frame yeah thank you I don't think it's
any different to what we encounter
um a lot and that sometimes we hear from
the same people every now and then it's
easier to move into a metaphorical eye
roll but equally renowned then if you
approach each approach from them
separately you've got to go actually no
that's a good point yeah that's right we
appreciate that thank you dare thank you
ringing uh just um to help us can we
have some I.T assistance so we can
forward emails at the moment we can't
upload emails to
um yeah we can't yeah okay well it can
be I'm sure rangi dealt with outside the
outside yeah
thank you for that fantastic Aaron Joe
thank you for that do appreciate your
this this actually
um in my experience getting around risk
committee this is a really important
area so I'm I'm grateful for the thought
that you focus put into it and hopefully
our comments add a wee bit to the
thinking
um uh but I take it in effect uh the
resolution is where you receive and we
we note essentially you outline that
you're gonna now you're now going to
work with in uh train yeah educate might
be the wrong word uh work with your
staff to be able to implement this
policy so the committee will be very
interested to see how it works thank you
um for a bunch of reasons I go back to
what Grant said at the West End it
actually correct you know it might
signal a level of risk actually the
other thing that I'm looking for is
actually particularly out of complaints
process we are we should be learning a
learning organization anything goes back
to your point Darren this could be a
good point how do we improve our service
to our community so be very interested
to see how it goes so thank you very
much do I have a move in a second happy
to make sure thank you Darren thank you
Leslie I'll put the Motions in please
all those in favor please say aye and
those against us carry brilliant thank
you thank you you too it's wonderful
great to have you here and Rihanna as
well I know you were ready to look like
you're ready to speak if you needed to
so there you go right can we move on to
the Strategic risk section please
um this is a very encouraging report
Andrew and I'm particularly appreciative
that we've got it on on the agenda
thank you
um so I'll take the reporters route
generally but I think it's important and
I think it picks up some coins from the
chair earlier and a lot of the issues
um that are coming up and a lot of the
issues that have been put before this
committee are connecting the dots and so
you see in this and the paper before
there was uh what was called by the
chair continuous Improvement but really
it's it's that second sort of stage of
our risk management maturity where we're
actually assessing whether or not the
controls and measures that we're putting
in place are actually being effective in
working the way we want them to and so
it's highlighting a little bit like we
have done here in the um by the material
outer Pro map where are things outside
where you would expect them to be where
are things not working as you would
expect them to and where are the control
Effectiveness where should you be
challenging those so there's and there's
a broad range of those things coming up
across the papers
um today
in terms of this paper in particular
it's just trying to highlight that and
it's something again that Council laws
and this committee should be uh very on
top of and that's those higher levels
sort of strategic risks we tend to get
particularly as staff we tend to get
bogged down in the day-to-day doing and
and where our operational risks are and
where the the obvious risks in many
respects are and don't spend enough time
uh or have the ability to
step up from that space and have a look
at the broader strategic risks and how
they might be impacting the decisions
we're making not necessarily immediately
but in that sort of two three four five
year time frame and what could or should
we be considering now in terms of how we
can mitigate the impact if any of those
risks when they're occurring
this is a follow-on to the paper that
went to council around the future for
local government and uh
encouraging even though that there is
some work going in that space and I
think the councils are looking at
working together in terms of forming a
joint approach to how they prepare for
that or look at what that might impact
but it's those sort of big changes that
have an impact on the decisions that
Council needs to make in terms of what
we can and should be doing for our
community the other risks that I think
are highlighted from the risks
identified by the previous Council uh
particularly related to our relationship
with other parties and how we need to
work on those relationships to ensure
that we can achieve things for the
community and how we can work within the
broader members and and parties within
the community that we need to work with
to achieve those outcomes and so it's
looking at trying to adjust our
risk framework to recognize those
strategic level risks and have a
conversation have a language in which we
can discuss those so that's the purpose
for today's paper
they said Andrew yes
look I think
it's such a valid point and that we are
entering a consultation period for our
ltp and that that really is the time
that we look at those strategic points
because we don't want to be Consulting
with the public willy-nilly I mean we
need to do it in a in a controlled
formal process then the ltp allows us to
do that and that three-year three-year
Gap where we do it especially when it
comes to things like what land are we
freeing up for housing what do we need
to do and and things thinking thinking
ahead
it actually puts more importance on the
ltp
um and previously in the 12 years I've
been on Council the ltp has come along
as a bit of a thing oh we've got to do
it but it should actually be used as a
really really aggressive and and
constructive tool
that's really as as Governors that's our
that's our piece to use really
um so I I really like the work and that
we should actually acknowledge it and
and actually
as Governors actually really get on
board
yeah thanks sir
any other questions comes Baron I'm not
just following on from what rangi was
saying it's it's right the ltp has
always been important because if we get
that right and there's no need for an
annual
um going out and revisiting an
adjustment apart from those rare
occasions where something phenomenal
happens like a global pandemic and
there's this great Almighty reset but
you know if
from a strategic perspective if we have
plan for that three slash ten slash 30
years
um and and done it well it's good and
part of that process is is making sure
that we manage those those risks
that said you know one good series of
sun spots that he raises everything and
every
um electronic cloud
is the next little challenge that we'll
face
absolutely Leslie thanks Mr chair
um
like the others I actually think this is
is very positive
um Andrew just wanted to say on page 42
in the chart
the second risk down
I think that one probably needs to refer
to the breakdown of relationships
you've got that you've got that risk
repeated twice there and I think the
first the first one is probably
referring to the breakdown of
relationships rather than the incorrect
sharing of information
thank you and when I read these I took
them verbatim from what came from the
workshop and I I when I looked at them
they will need some tweaking before they
come back after sexual risks so thank
you
thanks sir right Andrew look good it's
got probably on more at the
implementation into this because I I
totally agree with rangi and Darren this
is this is uh good stuff and in fact my
if I can make a comment rang in my my
viewers do you heard yards on the on the
ltp and I take your point you want to
say this and it should be an aggressive
document Progressive in terms of the
community
we need to back that then up with an
appropriate risk framework behind it to
make certainly achieve those objectives
which become really important
Andrew just like I take on board
um that was first that's actually my
first product I was going to make at
least we've got we've got it twice
although the descriptor description is
different ones around communication the
other one is around confidential
information
um sorry no no sorry one is one is
around yeah effective communication and
strategy are the one is about
relationship with stakeholders so
there's a wee bit there
um Andrew just so so look I like all the
side effects stuff I I mean I wasn't
directly involved in the creation of the
risk is 19 of them for my accounting is
correct that cat obviously came out of
the workshop My presumption is you're
now going to do analysis on that
um with a with a view that they will
bear shall we say a sorting or a sifting
of their risk waiting
um in those that are sort of extreme
high or residual risks are going to be
the ones that will monitor right
yes to a certain extent and I think the
other key piece and some when it's worth
acknowledging because you do a lot of
good work in this space through the
long-term plan but it then gets lost in
the long-term plan and I don't think we
ever plan
or consider to your point the counter
factual if our assumptions provedly
false and I think uh particularly where
we are Force through the process and
throughout New Zealand to make certain
assumptions that that staff and new
sales might not even agree with
um and yet we don't ever really sit back
and say okay we're about to assume
inflation of four percent or whatever it
is and none of us believe that whereas
what would that actually be
if the counter factual in which we
believe in case proves true and what
would we change we don't and that's
where the framework lets us build on the
work we're currently doing to have a
conversation around what is the
implication of those risks and where are
they currently sitting so that's not
necessarily a direct answer to your
question but but yes is the answer we
will use the language that we've now got
in the framework to have those
discussions and put a risk rating on all
our assumptions and all the risks that
we see and highlight some of these and
and what may or may not be happening in
these particular spaces because these
are risks that were identified by the
previous Council so clearly at that
stage we're thought to be important that
are not currently on our radar as risk
that we're managing
in a formal sense
I looked at the the risk management
framework
um oh actually no sorry one other
question Andrew on page 44 of 93
um under issues and options strategic
risks wasn't quite certain I could
understand that second sentence the
issue that has been identified in the
risk identification undertaken is that
there is a gap in the identified sources
of risks within the framework can you
just explain so when you look at the
descriptions of the the risks
um we've got a risk category called
strategy and policy when you look at the
wording around that it's really the
operational risks of not being able to
implement our strategy rather than the
risks that our strategy is incorrect or
invalid given the the so it's around the
strategy risk yes in contrast to
strategic risk okay I was thrown out by
the the by the by the title got it
that's fine which is then why when you
come to the table on page 45 it's only
dealing with strategy yes I understand
it now that's brilliant I knew my the
penny would drop in terms of the review
of the risk management policy
um I just want to make one question in
your paper you say you have or are
employing a risk yes yes so touch you
see behind us Anderson there's a lot of
work in the uh and it's in there a lot
of work at this stage around trying to
make sure our ability to manager is so
effectively through uh Pro map and
getting pro-map up to speed and and
useful for why we engaged it
and so preempting your question yes
there will be some changes to the titles
uh yeah and I spoke to Peter about that
Peter Patton about that and we'll need
to tweak some of the descriptions of
who's responsible for some of those yeah
within the policy yeah so they think
you're in front of me in terms of the
game
um who owns the risks
yeah ultimately cancel but we have and
and so again in the framework and and
we're just working through that in the
moment in terms of spreading out setting
it up in pro-map to ensure it reflects
our framework we have people who might
have sort of effectively day-to-day
management but ultimately all risks uh
would sit with the council but there
might be people on a day-to-day basis of
managing them to within and this is his
risk appetite piece to within the risk
appetite and what is the escalation if
you're not managing intuity in the
appetite set by Council
so that's all I within the framework and
we're formalizing it within Pro map so
we get those those steps to work and my
short-handers I'd be expecting owners to
come out of the elt on it one of my
risks oh to be honest and I'd love to
see you know this is down in the future
I'd love to see names when it goes with
it uh and we'll get that out of pro map
yeah I mean that that's I appreciate
we're we're in we're we're kicking off
here and this is really really good the
other thing that I would just want to
make a comment on is the table four on
page 60 of 93.
um uh again really good
um that we're trying to to categorize
um and it gives rise to to what
potentially hits this table or hits
Michael's elt table or sits with
manages a risk somewhere in the
organization
um only extreme risk goes to the audit
and risk committee I was wee bit
uncertain why it was only extreme risk I
would have expected at least High
look again happy for some guidance on
that uh it really and
I think inherent in that is an
expectation that if it was high then
there would be strategies put in place
to reduce it and if they couldn't be
then it would clearly be escalated so
it's more around I think uh who puts in
place the strategies or makes the
decisions but again happy for guidance
because we're in the process of setting
those escalation steps up formally
within the the model we've got so if you
would like that to come to risk
Insurance happy to make those changes
look I'm not suggesting a change right
now by the way Andrew this is just the
value of being able to see the documents
and have a discussion I think about
actually how does it how does it
actually apply and I related that I
could be I could be conflating two
issues with appendix B which is the
sources of risk and the consequences
which which often is also where we start
thinking about risk appetite and the
accounting me went straight to the
financial
which in some sense is the easiest one
to deal with because it's dealing with
dollars and I was just thinking you know
a moderate a moderate risk consequence
of a million to five million dollars I
suspect if we were running that as a
real risk that might be of interest to
this to this committee and again I'm
just thinking about actually what is the
escalation albeit that that actually I
mean it would still fit within your
framework you have a you have a risk we
know that it's it's it's moderate if you
couldn't bring it within the within the
million
five meanwhile we probably shouldn't be
having a discussion but I it will be
good I think ultimately to get to that
end of not only the front end work that
you guys are doing really well about
actually defining what our strategic
risks are and attaching it to our
objectives
but actually as you and I have discussed
that offline the risk appetite because
actually that then starts to create a
bit of sense of what should be in front
of this committee on a quarterly basis
and what shouldn't really appreciate
that and I think when just in briefly to
answer that one I think the the
difficulty often with looking at those
sources of riskies we tend to read them
in the uh without thinking about the
likelihood
and so again Financial risks for someone
like Council are actually quite low when
you look at the delegations and all the
other controls that embrace the
likelihood makes even a million dollar
uh
loss yeah
but I agree if it was likely in a
million dollars you'd probably see it
where I found this thing I just passed
this on to members I was again very
obviously the working with the lights
around page 76 and that little somewhat
deep busy diagram on the right hand side
of the page where
their experiences where probably
Governors and even managers Focus their
time versus where the real risk is and
that comes around Vu creation and I
think that's something wrong if I go
back to your original good comments
about the long-term plan we want to
focus on in terms of actually what what
do we do here it's got to be stuff that
creates value
and it's those big risks so a very
interesting very interesting little
diagram just to just to read it and I'm
glad we've got that one on board as part
of our um you know input to our thinking
which is really really good okay folk
I've look I've I'm risking having a
conversation here rather than trying to
do business are there any other Comics
Leslie um
and I hit was similar to yours about the
high risk on page 60. I did wonder in
that table whether
where it says these risks are to be
monitored monthly whether it perhaps did
need to Aid in may be escalated to risk
and assurance
is appropriate or something along those
lines
for the high risk
there would be a time at which it seems
to me elt
might appropriately make that decision
and it might be good to have up on the
table is is an option
look again happy to take on board those
comments and make those tweaks and I
suppose again it
it's the beauty of having these
conversations right it's getting that
agreed approach as much as anything when
we could we can try and Define a lot of
things we could try and write rules and
but but if we understand where
everyone's coming from we understand
that we're managing to an agreed risk
appetite then these things should flow
automatically it's important to have
them recognized in the words but but the
conversation will drive that to occur
anyway
you see I I again obviously clear you
and I aligned on on possibly a question
so on a point the question already
becomes where are we going to from here
and why don't we just look at the
recommendations in fact I think it gives
the sense Andrew you're characterizing
for us where you want to take us so if I
was to go very slowly through them we
received the report
we know the appropriate of the current
risk management framework and you've got
a couple of comments
um you've indicated that you'll change
it to
get a risk officer and Etc and there'll
be some weirding changes between the
computer's role as quality assurance so
that's that's super fine
we note the increase due to the risk
management framework in the development
of health and safety risks so we've seen
that there will get a chance to discuss
that to uplift it and that's giving us
an example an example of it of good risk
management we recommend that the changes
to the current appendix be
um so the risk management framework is
set out in this report and I just want
to check that's bringing those 19
defined risks into no no it's bringing
in the table on page
44 of board books 44.
uh and 45 the the descriptions so that
if if someone identifies the risks and
they go to manage that or go to the
framework to see how to manage it they
will have a a category process thank you
yeah consequence so that's page 40
That's page 44 which is the likelihood
rating yeah yeah and page 45 which is
the source of risk around strategy yeah
great got you because you've made those
changes we note the traditional
undermanned strategic risks by the
organization identifying the elective
member Workshop presentation and perhaps
even I've just under one of the key
little
reflects the professional View and we
request further report a we request say
further reporting strategic risk is
consistent with the newly defined
sources of risk and taking into
considerations that are identified and
Delight Workshop be presented to the
next risk and Assurance committee
meeting
it feels like quite a bit of work but I
take it it's underway so that's quite
achievable from your perspective Andrew
brilliant so this is the starting of a
the regular risk strategic risk work
that will be done as a committee which I
would want to totally endorse I think
those are the six recommendations
thank you Leslie thank you Darren are
there any comments on this
it's great work and tremendous so I
really am encouraged by it so I'll put
the motion all over please say hi
those against
Carrick sorry wrongy did you have your
hand oh look it's gone unfortunately it
crosses over to public excluding Council
so that's the trouble we've got topics
that
fall into this yeah yeah and it's
unfortunate that we are you referring to
the health and safety report ah no no no
no no no no yeah no so I think that's
can I just say that thank you for the
racing there I mean I think this is
something which we as uh we we need to
Enlighten where the Ombudsman goes
um in in lagoima what do we have in
public and what do we have in public
excluded my personal viewers this is in
the right place by the way
um and we but we may have to start
considering
um actually what is transacted publicly
versus what is not so for instance
um if I can give some Reflection from my
committees elsewhere cyber security is
often seen as one of our strategic risks
we never have well we wouldn't discuss
cyber security in public in public
because actually it's not the sort of
thing you want to let those that want to
break into the system know what you're
doing so we will need to we'll need to
work that one through so your point I
want to say wrong is really well made
um but we're with babes in the wooden
tombs that where do we discuss strategic
risk so we need to we need to work that
one out
I agree
so I think that's a future work on
Andrew you may have comments you're also
my well and Michael we're our legal
advisors you may want to you may want to
indicate any thoughts on that at this
stage I don't know
no we'll worry about it as it goes on
that's great groovy so can we go back to
the agenda then please
um we uh
um we're up to item nine which I've said
I'd like to hold over
um I did produce uh um a very short
um three or four page PowerPoint uh deck
where I put out my thoughts in terms of
where the committee's at
um for reasons which which are possibly
technical it was never uploaded
um so look I would just like to suggest
that we hold that over gives you a
chance to get my views um and then it
gives us a chance to have a proper
discussion at the next meeting without
too much trouble
um could we move then to item 10 which
is to move into public excluded for
these items and the reason started I'll
move that from the chair do I have a
secondary
thank you Leslie is there any discussion
on what we're taking into public
experience
comfortable good I'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
aye those against this Carrie brilliant
I think you're going to